I'm Uta Francke. I'm a Human Geneticist originally from Germany as you can hear.
And I'm an Emeritus Professor here at
Stanford and also Senior Medical Director at 23andMe.
>> So, we have three billion based pairs and just one copy
of the human genome. And we, we've learned that, you know we have
two copies of the human genome of the nuclear genome in, in our
cells. And we've been learning a bit about the coding regions, the protein
coding regions. what, what can you tell us about the relative size of
the protein coding regions of the genome versus the sort of non coding regions?
>> The big question was how many protein coding genes
are there in the genome? And initially, before the genome project
the, the number that's been kicked around was like 100,000.
Sort of, a wild guess. And then, between 2000 and 2003,
there was an official betting game going on
where people could put down a dollar and a
number. And then years later, it was $5 and then it was $20 because in a way, it
became more difficult. And everybody could only put on
down one bet. About 150 people put down the
bet, and their range, the ranges of their guesses
went from, you wouldn't believe it. 25,000 to 150,000.
>> Wow.
>> So nobody had really any good idea.
The mean was around 61,000 genes. And when the
first draft was published they said, well we had a brief look at it and we think
it's between 30 and 35,000. And when it
was finally finished, the number had come down to
20 to 25,000. And many people were surprised because
this is hardly any more than the, the round
worm or the fruit fly. So the humans are so much
more complex, shouldn't they have more protein coding genes? So the
complexity cannot be immediately dedu, deduced from the number of genes,
when you don't know what these, these genes can be used for.
>> So what percentage of the genome
is actually made up of coding region, roughly?
>> It's only 1 to 2%. And so all this other,
you know, 90, 98 to 99% then. I mean, a lot of people who you know, are
just learning about the genome may be wondering,
what exactly is the rest of that sequence doing?
>> You see, originally people thought it was just junk.
It was just a virus getting in and replicating itself.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, in recent years, people started to look at how much of that
sequence is being made into RNA. How
much is being transcribed. And to everyone's
surprise more than 80% is actually made into a copy of RNA. And these RNAs have
all kinds of interesting functions. For example, to regulate activity of
other genes. To regulate the activity of messenger RNAs, how they are being
translated. And many different function that the
RNAs have. Some of them are structural.
There are RNA set as structural components
of the ribosome. And otherwise, outside of the
coding sequence are control regions that are
important to regulate the activity of each gene.
>> I see. So, we learn in this lesson about messenger RNA.
>> Mm-hm.
>> mRNA. And so what you're saying, there are actually other kinds of
RNAs that can be made besides mRNA that doesn't get turned into protein?
>> That's right.
And what was found out recently, that you remember
there are two strands in the DNA and the messenger
RNAs only made of one strand that gives the
information for the protein. But what is being found out
now is that there are anti-sense RNAs that actually
the other strand of DNA can also be made into
RNA. It goes in the opposite direction. It has
no coding function for proteins, usually not, sometimes it does.
But it has regulatory function. And you just can imagine, if a gene
is transcribed in the other direction, then
the transcription of the messenger RNA has
a problem. You know, it runs into, it's a train wreck, right? So
there was a regulation of gene activity by anti sense RNA that's one mechanism.
>> Right. So it sounds like maybe some of the
complexity of different species or complexity of cells is in part
not so much the, the sheer content. The number of genes you have,
but maybe how you regulate all of those genes together to, to create something.
>> What we are finding out now is that the genomic
regions communicate with each other. Like you can have an enhancer region
that is downstream away from the gene or even in an entrant
of another gene that then falls over, communicates with the promoter and
sets in motion the messenger RNA sentences. So the
whole genome is three-dimensional. It's not just a one
dimensional series of letters. There's a lot of three-dimensional
arrangement and interaction that's very important for its function.